僕たちもうそんなに長くないんだ
そんな悲しいこと言うなよ
俺たちまだ出会ったばっかりじゃないか
ごめん、はじめん
でも、もやしはすぐだめになっちゃうんだ
バカヤロー
諦めんなよ
はじめん？
なんだよ
僕たちの最後の願いを聞いて？
ああ
俺にできることだったらなんだってするよ
僕たちを食べて。
俺にそんなことはできない
俺にそんなことはできない！
はじめん！
このままだと僕たちはダメになってしまうんだ
だからおねがい
せめて
せめてはじめんに食べられたいんだ
うっうっ
わかった
あ、目に染みる
わかったよ
俺がお前らもやしを
おいしくする！
こんにちは
料理研究家のはじめしゃちょーです
今日もさっそくクッキングをやっていきましょう
実はもやしってすごい鮮度が大切なんだ
だからもやしは一日放置するだけでもすごい悪くなってしまう
というわけで今日は
この私天才料理家はじめーんが
みんなでも簡単に作れる
手軽レシピを僕が
感覚とノリで
誰でも簡単に作れるもやしの料理を作ってみようと思います
では行こう
マジで食べれるかわかんねーんだよなー
材料はこちら
ネギ、ピーマン、にんじん、鶏肉、きゃべつ、キムチ
魚肉ソーセージ
たまご
そしてメインの
（チュッ）
もやし
んー
なにもわからない
とりあえず
水回りを洗おう
とりあえず水回りを洗います
なんでこんなこと急にやりだすかというと
実家に帰ってさ、マジで料理しなきゃと思ったわけよ
じゃあとりあえず野菜類を水洗いしていきましょう
♪パーパラパラパラ
ヘヘイ！
♪パラパラパラ
♪パラパラ
♪ッパラパラパラ
♪ア.パーラ.パーラ
♪パラパラパラ
卵も洗うよ
卵もわからんからね
おーけー役者はそろった
お肉系はとりあえずもう早く焼いといたほうがいい気がする
お肉焼きましょう
OK！
オイルをやんないと焦げるって聞いたんで
あっ！
ああー待って！
あーーー！
あ、まってやばいマジでやばいマジでやばい
うわやベー
待ってみんな早いね
すごい早い色つくの
焼肉のたれ入れます
よしよしよし、いいよ
おっけーうまそううまそう
やべ皮むき器がねーな、どうしよう
皮むき器がないのでちょっと大根おろしで何とか
あ、全然だめだ
もうもやし入れようか
でもキャベツキャベツキャベツ入れよう
まずキャベツ入れましょう
いいよー
いいいいいい
千切り感でてるよ
じゃあネギもネギもこの調子で行ってみよう
おーいいよー
体にいいからねネギは
ピーマンは知ってんだよね
ピーマンはここをくりぬかないとだめなんすよ
いいんじゃない、こんな感じで
おっけ
ここでもやしをぶち込みます
ファイヤー！
アッツ待って熱い
しっかり肉汁と絡めます
意外とはさみでも剥けますね
なんか違うな
ほいさ
待って、魚肉ソーセージ忘れてた
あ！
キムチキムチ
ちょっとピリ辛感を出していきたいですねキムチで
も、ちょっとでいいんで、ちょっとピリ辛感を
おーっけおっけおっけおっけ
おっけおっけおっけ
これでしばらく炒めましょう
分かんない、俺マジで何も見てないからね
もうほんと
完全感覚ドリーマーでやったから
おーけ―
完成
完全感覚
もやし炒め
こんなね、味もないもやしを何とかして作ったのがこちらのもやし炒め
僕のなかではもやし炒めじゃありません
これは立派な
創作料理
何も見てないからほんとに
マジ感覚で作った
いただきマスタング少佐
いただきます
熱い
あ！
うまいぞ
うまいうまいうまい
んー
魚肉ソーセージも入れて間違いではなかったな
うまいよ
味付けほぼ焼き肉のたれぶち込んだくらいであんまりしてないんですけど
おいしいです
まってうまい
おかわり
いやーちょっとねぇ
料理やってこう
たまにしか出せないかもしんないんですけど
頑張って料理やってこうと思います
健康だしね
そう、俺だって今おかしも
でちゃった
お菓子も食ってないしジュースも飲んでない
そして自炊をする
健康ですよ
ゴット
不健康な生活してるんでこういうね
自炊からでもいいからしっかりやっていければいいなと思います
みなさんぜひやってみてください
じゃあな